bonsoir à tous
je vais vous demander
de sortir un outil formidable de votre
poche cet outil là et de le porter le
plus haut possible au dessus de votre
tête
personne n'a l'air d'avoir de difficulté
ça n'a pas l'air très lourd à votre avis
ça pèse combien cet outil 300 g de 100
grammes 169 en vérité cet outil là il
pèse mille milliers de milliers de
milliers de milliers de milliers de
livres c'est peut-être le plus grand
super pouvoirs qu'on ait découvert
depuis l'atome et pour la plupart
d'entre nous on ne s'en sert pas
complètement
suivez-moi moi je voulais être
explorateurs chacun son truc
je voulais aller de ce côté-là des
cartes vous voyez qui encore inexploré
où tout est possible mais je suis né
trop tard pour ça la terre est
complètement cartographier on peut
prendre n'importe quel coin du monde et
y aller comme ça en un clic
trop tard alors je me suis dit je
pourrais peut-être faire partie de ceux
qui exploreront l'univers mais pour sa
trop tôt même si je fais partie les
descendant del bosque sont beaucoup
beaucoup plus jeune que moi et donc il
est trop tôt pour ça peut-être
scientifique j'ai pensée scientifique
scientifique c'est une façon dans un
champ bien précis d'aller lever le voile
sur des choses inconnues
notre forme d'exploration mais j'ai
découvert en terminale que les
mathématiques que j'y faisais qui était
déjà complexe avait été inventé pour
certaines ya deux mille ans et puis pour
les plus récentes ya 300 ans donc il me
restait au bas mot 300 ans de grands
esprits à singer a assimilé à copier
avant d'espérer peut-être pouvoir mettre
ma pierre je suis pas hyper convaincu et
puis j'ai eu mon premier job étudiant je
remplaçais pendant l'été une salariée
d'une grande banque française
et avant de partir m'a laissé
l'instruction voilà ton job toute la
journée c'est que tu reçois une centaine
de tableaux excel le matin et puis tu
dois leur faire subir une série de
manipulations l'agrandît tel colonnes
mais tel titre en gras etc
ça prend toute la journée c'est je vous
laisse deviner horriblement ennuyeux le
deuxième jour je reviens je me dis c'est
pas possible
en 2007 il doit avoir une façon plus
intelligente de faire ça moi j'entends
parler partout de start-up
d'automatisation intelligence
artificielle ou est déjà à l'époque
hélas non je fais une petite recherche
sur un moteur de recherche connu et je
découvre les macros excel
donc j'espère vous connaissez votre
spécialisation les macros excel sinon
vous avez rentabiliser votre temps ce
soir c'est un petit bouton en haut vous
appuyez dessus c'est un registre que
vous faites et puis à la fin vous
associer sa raccourci raccourcis et à
chaque fois que vous ferez ce raccourci
sa relance toute la manipulation donc
j'avais en fait automatisés ce travail
là je vais aller voir mon chef de
l'époque je dis ben voilà ce que j'ai
découvert et il a supprimé
l'excellent en question vous laisse
deviner pourquoi et il m'a muté sur un
autre job que je pouvais pas automatisé
donc le sanctions en fait mais j'ai eu
un déclic je me dis attend antoine ça
veut dire qu'il ya des savoirs dans tout
le monde parle comme s'il était acquis
qui sont là sur une étagère à prendre la
poussière pendant que les praticiens qui
en auraient besoin
et là je parle d'une institution une
banque que quand même spécialisée dans
le traitement de l'information qui a des
ressources qui a du temps libre
les praticiens qui auraient besoin de
ces savoirs en réalité ne s'en servent
pas ou ne les connaissent pas il ya
quelque chose qui s'est perdue il ya un
an que deux connecteurs ça manque
d'archiviste de personnes qui vont aller
chercher c'est sa voix et qui ont les
transformer les connecter les assembler
pour ceux qui en ont besoin
alors j'ai choisi de faire un métier qui
permet de faire ça toute la journée je
suis devenu entrepreneur alors il ya
certainement d'autres métiers qui
permettent de trouver des raccourcis
mais entrepreneurs davantage quand vous
trouvez un raccourci vous finissez
plutôt vous gagnez plus d'argent
vous avez plus d'impact sur le monde
alors que dans beaucoup de métiers
malheureusement vous verrez quand on
trouve des raccourcis ensuite taper
dessus et ceux dont j'aimerais vous
convaincre ce soir c'est que si vous
êtes ce type d'explorateurs si vous avez
ce type de curiosité vous êtes né au
parfait moment on est là on est parfaite
génération pour faire ça on est assis
sur une quantité donnée une date à ce
faire qui je vous le disais tout à
l'heure
équivalente un million de milliards de
livres ces 10 milliards de bibliothèque
d'alexandrie vous savez une des plus
grandes bibliothèques de l'histoire
et ça ça tient dans notre poche vous
êtes littéralement assis dessus
alors bien sûr là dedans il ya beaucoup
de photos de chats mais il ya aussi
plein de savoir de raccourcis de
superpouvoirs inexploité en plus nous
avons des alliés inédit pour aller
fouiller cette bibliothèque dans des
outils d'archiviste exceptionnel dans
l'histoire
nous avons des moteurs de recherche
extrêmement puissant vous les connaissez
vous connaissez peut-être pas et que qui
valait le coup d'être cité je pense
c'est google scholar une version de
google qui permet de fouiller la
littérature scientifique
vous aurez accès à des extraits
virtuellement vous avez accès à toutes
les publications scientifiques de tous
les domaines du monde
on a les ted pour découvrir des idées de
manière ludique en à wikipédia pour ce
cas un avis nuancé et objectif sur
n'importe quel sujet on a ue pour
apprendre des séquences de gestes et
puis on a plus que jamais dans
l'histoire accès aux livres
on s'est tous lire ou presque maintenant
ça aussi c'est exceptionnel alors si je
vous convainc que ça peut être un job
marrant pour vous et vous verrez les
entreprises en ont besoin d'être des
passeurs de savoir des connecteurs de
choses qui auraient pas dû être
connectés et d'amener ça aux praticiens
que faut-il pour devenir archiviste que
faut-il pour devenir ce type
d'explorateurs d'abord mon premier
conseil c'est de questionner questionner
les méthodes qu'on vous propose parce
qu'en fait dans le grand jeu de l'oie
qu'on va vous proposer pour votre vie il
n'y a pas beaucoup de choses qui
pourraient pas être amélioré vous mettez
ce que vous voulez améliorer pour
certaines personnes c'est peut être
gagner du temps pour d'autres ça peut
être faire sa manière plus plaisante etc
mais il ya plus de choses qui
résisterait pas à un ou deux trésors de
cette gigantesque bibliothèque que nos
ancêtres ont accumulés ces quatre cent
dernières années
ce qu'il faut vraiment cinq ans pour
obtenir un master par exemple une
question qu'on se pose trop peu parce
que les étudiants sont contents de faire
plus de soirées étudiantes
les écoles sont contents d'avoir des
étudiants plus longtemps et avec les
parents qui sont pas contents mais
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment cinq ans pour
apprendre ce que vous apprenez peut-être
qu'on pourrait faire plus vite on faire
mieux faire plus agréable laissez moi
vous donner
je vous ai fait une petite sélection de
super pouvoirs pour vous ce soir
qui me semblent adaptés à votre
situation vous allez passer vos examens
en plein qu'ovide cet hiver
vraisemblablement or on sait trésors de
la bibliothèque étagères immunologie ans
est depuis le début des années 90 que le
stress des grades l'air les défenses
immunitaires
si vous avez été très stressé pendant un
mois par exemple alors fausse exams vous
avez deux fois plus de chances de
contracter un rhume pas de vols vu le
contexte mais autres étagères on sait
étagères sciences du sport par exemple
on sait que le sport vous permet de
mieux gérer l'anxiété renforce le
système immunitaire votre sommeil
et en bonus les découvertes s'accumulent
pour faire pour laisser penser que ça
nous rend plus intelligent le sport ça
protège notre cerveau de la
dégénérescence qui commence à 20 ans
alors vous n'avez pas le temps de faire
oui surtout si vous fêtez sur l'étudiant
mais vous n'avez peut-être pas le temps
de faire du sport donc une autre
technique un autre raccourci pour vous
l'entraînement haute intensité technics
partie votre étagère
on peut mixer les choses c'est pas
interdit en 20 minutes d'entraînement
haute intensité vous avez l'essentiel
des bénéfices physiologique d'une heure
d'endurance classique vous n'avez pas 20
minutes
laissez moi vous donner un dernier petit
raccourci les raccourcis clavier
justement alors vous travaillé une bonne
partie du temps sur un ordinateur
beaucoup d'entre vous il parce qu'on
leur tend les prochaines années et
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait trouvé mieux que le
clavier pour entrer d'information si
vous appreniez les 25 raccourci les plus
courants c'est pas la mer à boire
voir des gens me reconnaissent que trois
ou quatre vous gagneriez au bas mot huit
jours par an ce que je vais vous dire
c'est que ces raccourcis
c'est pas des vains mots serre que c'est
pas pour se faire plaisir au cerveau
qu'on découvre ces choses là c'est quand
les combinant on peut vraiment changer
votre vie si vous appliquez juste les
trois petits conseils que je viens de
vous donner vous verriez vous vivriez
plus longtemps en meilleure santé
intellectuelle vous seriez moins
stressés vous dormirez y est mieux vous
passeriez moins de temps à prendre vos
leçons
vous partiriez plutôt du travail plus
tard donc vous voyez c'est vraiment des
super pouvoirs seule chose qu'on peut
connecter et peu de gens finalement les
utilisent vraiment ces dernières
découvertes peu de gens utilisent le
pouvoir de cet outil que vous avez dans
la poche
donc si vous voulez devenir archiviste
la première chose c'est de questionner
comme je vous le disais n'acceptait pas
les méthodes telles quelles la deuxième
chose que je vous conseille c'est avant
de vous spécialiser
assurez vous que vous avez les clés
qui permettent d'ouvrir tous les champs
du savoir avant de venir les chiens de
traîneau assurez vous que vous êtes déjà
des renards qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
vire tous les champs de savoir les
techniques d'apprentissage si vous savez
à prendre mémoriser vous discipliner
aujourd'hui vous pouvez tout apprendre
ou réapprendre à faire des falafels
alors on a mené jamais fait vous pouvez
apprendre
moi ma premier entreprises j'ai créé
dans le nucléaire j'avais fait des
études de sciences sociales d'ailleurs
le doyen nous avait reçu la première
année en dix ans après après ses études
là vous pouvez tout faire à part
peut-être la physique nucléaire
j'ai appris la physique des rayonnements
j'ai appris quasiment tout seul avec les
ressources dont je vous parle et je vous
dis pas ça pour dire que je suis
exceptionnel vous pouvez c'était
impossible ya 25 ans mais aujourd'hui
vous pouvez le faire si vous savez à
prendre donc la première clé qu'il vous
faut c'est être capable de tout apprend
la deuxième c'est la culture générale
plus vous êtes cultiver plus vous pouvez
faire des liens entre des choses
improbables la troisième clé pour être
un renard pour tout ouvrir c'est la
débrouillardise informatique plus vous
êtes débrouillard sur vos outils et
contrairement à ce qu'on imagine souvent
il suffit pas d'être jeune pour être
super bon avec un ordinateur mais plus
vous êtes bon avec votre ordinateur
votre smartphone plus vous pouvez
accéder à des savoirs qu'on n'aurait pas
voulu que vous ayez je parle pas de
hacker mais je veux dire des savoirs pas
prémâché pas présélectionné pour vous la
dernière clé pour être un renard c'est
l'esprit critique parce que dans cette
gigantesque bibliothèque
il ya plein de trucs supers et plein de
vraie science solide mais aussi plein de
choses qui font semblant d'être de la
science est plein de failles news etc et
donc ne pouvait exploiter ces savoir que
si vous apprenez à faire le distinguo
entre le vrai et le faux donc fin des
notions statistiques quelque un petit
peu de culture scientifique savoir
distinguer une bonne source d'une
mauvaise une tentative de manipulation
d'une présentation sincère si vous savez
faire ça poser des questions et ouvrir
toutes les portes du savoir
alors vous pouvez des connecteurs des
gens qui vont assembler les trésors les
super pouvoirs dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui pour mieux vivre mieux
soigner mieux dormir mieux aimé mieux
travailler mieux apprendre et ça moi ça
m'a réconcilié avec mon rêve d'enfant
parce que je me suis dit que si je
faisais pas partie des générations qui
vont aller explorer les étoiles je peux
au moins contribué je peux au moins être
de celles qui vont leur créer les super
pouvoirs
les méthodes dont ils auront besoin pour
cette reconquête je remercie de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]